we've been in some hard spots before
but we've always made it through
yeah with mom and dad there to help us
who knows where they are now
i try not to think about them
it's not terrible
because when i do
i wonder if there was something else i
could have done
to keep us all together
we need to make it to the colony safely
what are you doing tell the robot to
stop that's not where we want to go wait
those are jupiters that's our parents
why would we show us this
these robots are relentless
they will tear the jupiters apart to try
and find the location of our kids
well he wants something from will he
always has
the robots are gonna come for me
danger
robinson
maybe the only way to put an end to this
is to face the danger
[Music]
[Music]
hold on everyone
[Music]
why aren't you scared
who says i'm not
sometimes you have to walk into dark
places
sometimes it's the only way to protect
the people you love
[Applause]
which seat's mine i thought you were
supposed to be dead i was supposed to be
a lot of things
none of those worked out either
we have to listen to the youth otherwise
we are doomed to have sex with only old
people
[Music]
we're going to go on vacation ireland
you're not as irish as i can be as irish
as you are
yes
this dude is like the irish version of
me we're into like a lot of the same
stuff ghouls and cheese and
ghouls
welcome to my acting workshop people in
positions of power will try and bang you
i don't trade roles for sex damn
feminists ruin everything fine
i'm in business with jeffrey epstein
what i was on the sex island but only
for the snorkeling oh
michael kelly dying from eating rocks
which he thought were eggs man i made
that mistake
[Applause]
i want to become a catholic priest i
only want the big man upstairs the only
man that can fill me up well him and a
son and the holy spirit i'll take all
three of them at once it's only sunny in
philadelphia the all-new season
premieres december 1st on fxx next day
fxr
let's go back to the beginning
it was supposed to be over
he's following me
and what about the breathing exercises
that we practiced are those helpful
[Music]
you said your dad was writing a book
about amy and gray feathered serpent
we're gonna change the world
shut us down
someone tried to hack the pentagon
i have to stop this you have school
people are in danger and if that means
having to do the department's job for
them then that's what i have to do
this is my game nobody beats me
we dropped you into the deep end of a
world that you're not quite ready for
[Music]
don't make me your enemy
too late
get out of there
[Music]
yesterday morning
two bodies were found buried in the back
garden of the house
the more we run the more guilty we'll
see we cannot confirm the circumstances
under which they came to be buried in
that location
it's just you
and me
we just have to stick to the planet
state's the plan
[Music]
susan oh hello
16 years ago
william and patricia witcherly each shot
twice
and buried in the rear garden of their
own house
susan edwards along with her husband
christopher then set about conceding
both the deaths for the next 15 years
yes no comment this your signature no
comment it's okay susan sorry that's my
signature sir
[Music]
they'll try to confuse you but don't let
them i want you to try something rest of
the head spit
you remember you're in charge
your husband's opted not to take legal
advice
it's chris talking you told my
colleagues everything he can susan
you've not seen your parents for over a
year
then suddenly you pay them a visit and
then they die no comment
this doesn't paint a very pretty picture
does
it we go
everything is going to be all right just
needs a little bit of clearing up that's
all
chris what does it do
i have to stand up for my wife
susan could never have killed that is
impossible this is the truth you have to
believe me
some people are beyond help
nobody is beyond help in this world
that's the whole point
of this world
she's calling me a murderer
it's not what it seems it didn't happen
like this
the whole lot of you are liars
stick to the plan
it's gonna be all right
[Music]
my favorite movie is american gangster i
will be having a third talk with your
mom about what you're watching at home
i'm janine teagues i've been teaching
second grade here at abbott elementary
for a year now the staff here is
incredible there is a seven-year-old
custodian who voted for kanye teaching
social studies
that's who runs the world kids
i'm looking for miss coleman hello come
to the sub oh i thought one of my
colleagues here hired a stripper for me
okay
the main problem in the school district
is yeah no money he tried to plus the
toilet the water shot back up in the air
no one told you about reversey toilet no
why is that even a thing
when the world sees just a day in the
life of being a teacher here you get
used to it in that smell on the wall oh
no you're never gonna get used to this
okay
the more i live
the more i find that if you have good
friends in your corner anything's
possible
carrie party of three
future is unwritten because we're all at
different stages of life tonight bring
your a game
how many dating apps are you on i am
just waiting for someone to create a
dating site that's called here's the man
you've been searching for sima
this is x y and me what about you carrie
have you ever masturbated in a public
place
not since barney's closed
oh honey i'm home
i remember when you kept your sweaters
in the stove
[Music]
they're always going to be roads not
taken so you can't have it all no you
can it's just really hard
you're not happy with who you are
step out of that box and change
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and just like that
after all the years
and all the changes
[Music]
you're still
you hello lovers
[Music]
we're wounded
broken
trying desperately to keep ourselves
going by pretending we're not
poor poor uh
doesn't know we should get her food and
water
welcome to the bill
cds will be the capital city of our
belter nation
a place all belters and forever call
home i just received words they've been
located in our assistant
you have something in mind
i do
permission to come aboard
what's going on the old lady leaves the
rossi as the best option for this
operation
are you getting paid actually for this
there's a war on
captain drummer we was golden bow
now we fight with you
good i'm ready for a fight
a war will come soon enough
my time calm we'll be ready
holy [ __ ]
what is it
a motherlode
[Music]
he's better with you at his site
how do i say philip and i failed firing
one
[Music]
in the end
the only thing that matters is fighting
for who's covering your back
i want about to see what it's doing to
us
i want them to see the lives we've lost
the pain we've suffered
[Music]
i never loved you because you were
fighters
i loved you because you were builders
we need something
to give us a reason
[Music]
who's there
and now every man's very weird fantasy
let the women's gelatin wrestling begin
stop this is really toxic patrick if you
want to compete get this man a bikini
bear in the castle is ruined and we are
broke i'd rather be dead than poor me
too but that's one of those things
you're not supposed to say out loud it
makes you sound like a real [ __ ]
patrick we need to get rich again or
else our kingdom is gonna get conquered
the knights are returning they're up
here to save us
let's get messed up
what
now let's find a home for all these
bonuses
we're literally going to die
i'm starving and no one will give me
money if it's gold you know what let's
play
i want a skull
feed me those cursed gems
it doesn't make any sense
i replaced my nipples with gems
keep your tits in your tongue
your rightful ruler is back from the
dead yet rascals what's happening the
old king hijacked the throne jacked it
and he's completely nuts
nuts there's going to be changes around
here
the kingdom's next top queen y'all
queens who need to impress the king now
turn around so i can watch
how is it always up to me to save the
kingdom do you want to play it safe
or do you want to be a [ __ ] legend
i love a good patrick saves the day
scheme what's the plan barney get me one
of your handkerchiefs
has anyone laughed at this ever not even
the smallest child
away
we have to save patrick before it's too
late
mom what are you doing i think we can
take them
you know what i did the math wrong we
absolutely cannot take them
oh this is the worst day ever you know
what'll take the edge off
a little poison
that's savage
uh hey excuse me
is this because of that thing
uh
should i go somewhere
you should go home
[Music]
i can't see you
i stood
looking over the damage
[Music]
trying to remember the sweetness of life
on earth
but there is no before
only now
[Music]
i was late
you were early
and adrift
in a stranger's galaxy for a long long
time
i have found you nine times before
maybe ten
then i'll find you again
there is no rescue mission
we are safe
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
this strange and awful time
was the happiest of my life
[Music]
in the beginning god said let there be
light and there was light
over the next six days god created the
earth and sea the sun moon and stars
animals and humankind
on the seventh day god rested
and on the eighth day god woke up
refreshed from his nap
and made what most agree is his finest
creation yet
[Music]
spread the word you freaking turds
something has changed girl
the world's acting strange these days
the north and southern war
monsters roaming wonders should be
hibernating
maybe it's the end of days
i've lived through three supposed end of
days
it's all horseshit
this continent
was meant for no one
none of us will have any peace
[Music]
that's my home
my fight
[Music]
your precious leaders after something
you're a pawn to get to it
rebuild our faucets
strengthen our numbers
we are an empire
the war's just begun
[Music]
i can consume you
are you ready for this
if what you say about that girl's power
is true
you can't help her
legend
and we need your help
fine but first
gentlemen it's been an honour
what
i made new friends get over it
jealous
i heard a thousand
but none stories
describe this place
it must be witnessed to be understood
and yet
i've seen it
and understand it even less than before
i first cast eyes on this place
[Music]
there were two journeys
one was filled with danger and death and
despair
[Music]
the other adventure and wonder
i was on the letter
and i loved it
[Music]
you weren't poor
you weren't
desperate the road west is filled with
failures
failure isn't what drove him
[Music]
it was a dream
[Music]
and the dream is coming true
[Music]
are you okay
when i went to go say goodbye to
gabrielle it turned into the most
incredible night of sex that i've ever
had in my entire life get it girl no
what
[Music]
gabriel has decided to stay in paris but
there's something else behind this i
just don't know yet what it is
i need to explain myself the more you
say the worse it sounds which is why i
have to talk to her oh that sounded
desperate
it used to be so decisive and ever since
i moved to paris my life has just been
chaotic and dramatic and
complicated
oh emily you're getting more french by
the day
it's not easy to speak our feelings but
don't waste time with girls
this is just such a huge mess
i can't just magically transform into
someone who doesn't care
you need to decide what you want and not
what's gonna make everyone else happy
[Music]
[Music]
you've got the rest of your life to be
as dull as you wish
but while you're here
fall in love
make mistakes
if you're gonna do paris for one year
for god's sake do it right
[Music]
[Applause]
the only cop show they forgot to cancel
is back 30911's news special on
paramount plus side reno number one has
done it again what does that even mean
i love the voice you're not we did it we
just did it again what
it
it says everything about it in it reno
9-1-1 has done it again i like it let's
go with that one yeah
rio 911
we want to live the american dream
ain't nobody gonna do it for us but us
we're starting over
we might not get this chance again
i got a plan
we're gonna take the oxy
and sell it right underneath the fat
man's nose
dazna stole your pills
you don't have to kill her to destroy
her
[Music]
let's build a damn empire
[Music]
december 26th on tnt
i am not a bounty hunter
i've heard otherwise
[Music]
i know that you sit on the throne of
your former employer
jabber ruled with fear
i intend to rule with respect
you were all once captains under jabba
the hutt
i'm here to make a proposal that's
mutually beneficial
why speak of conflict
when cooperation can make us all rich
what prevents us all from killing you
and taking what we want
[Music]
if he had spoken such insolence to jabba
he'd have fed you to his menagerie
please
speak freely
[Music]
[Applause]
fasten your key tie your belt
karate is coming to the world's biggest
stage
where legends are born
welcome back to the all valley karate
tournament
[Music]
the soul of the valley is on the line
have the man voice filled you in on the
whole mortal enemy karate dojo battling
for the soul the valley thing
it's true you bring out the best
[Music]
[Music]
you